The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NEHA NARULA: OK, let's
go ahead and get started.
So Tadge is in
California today, so he
asked me to give
today's lecture, which
will be based on
a research project
that we're working
on at the DCI.
This is actually
really connected
to confidential transactions
and confidential assets,
which I think that you guys
covered in a previous class.
So Pedersen commitments will
play a very important role
in the work I'm
about to present.
I want to present this
work that we've been doing.
This is joint work with Willy
Vasquez, who was an MIT M.Eng.
He graduated and moved
to UT-Austin, and Madars
Virza, who is a research
scientist with the DCI.
And this project
is called zkLedger.
It's about
privacy-preserving auditing
for distributed ledgers.
So to start with, I
am not sure how much
work you guys have done on
permissioned blockchains
so far.
How much have you
covered with respect
to permissioned blockchains?
Nothing at all?
OK.
Should we start with what is
a permissioned blockchain,
or do you guys feel like
you have a handle on what
that means or what that is?
In its most generic,
abstract sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does it just mean that
different people have access
to see parts of the chain?
NEHA NARULA: Yeah.
So, good question.
OK, so these words that we
use-- permissioned versus
permissionless--
usually refer to who
has right access to the chain.
So in cryptocurrencies
like Bitcoin and Ethereum,
theoretically, any one of us
could spin up our own ASIC,
get really lucky, mine a
block, and put the transactions
that we are interested
in into the chain.
Now of course, no one's
going to accept that block
if it violates the majority
consensus rules of the chain.
But assuming that it follows
the rules, it's well formatted,
it has the appropriate proof of
work, et cetera, any one of us
could submit a block to
the Bitcoin blockchain.
Right?
There's no permissions
on who is allowed
and who isn't allowed to write
to the Bitcoin blockchain.
Permissioned blockchains
are a different story.
These are more like
distributed databases.
The idea behind
permissioned blockchains
is that you choose a set
of actors ahead of time,
and only those
actors are allowed
to write to the blockchain.
So you can't just have
anyone willy-nilly
spinning up a mining
node, or spinning up
a node in the system, and
submitting transactions
and things to the blockchain.
Usually, permissioned
versus permissionless
doesn't say anything
about reads,
and who can read the blockchain.
We're really just
talking about rights.
So an important use--
permissioned
blockchains, I think,
are not really the focus
of this course, in part
because we take the position
that the technology behind them
is essentially
distributed databases.
And there's lovely courses out
there on distributed databases.
And there's a lot
to learn about them,
and they're very interesting,
but they're not necessarily
very closely related
to cryptocurrencies
and the designs of
the past decade.
So that's the idea behind
permissioned blockchains.
Now, as I was saying,
I think that there's
a lot of use cases for
permissioned blockchains.
They're very useful.
Distributed databases, in
general, are very useful.
And so let's talk
about one of them.
And I'm going to interchangeably
use permissioned blockchain
and distributed ledger, here.
Distributed ledger,
permissioned blockchain,
I'm sort of saying
the same thing.
So permissioned
blockchains-- any questions,
before we dive into the
use case in zkLedger,
about permissioned blockchains?
Get the idea?
It's a whole bunch of
people working together
to construct a ledger.
So let's start
with the structure
of the financial system.
And this is setting the
use case for zkLedger,
and what we were
trying to do, and what
we were trying to address.
So to start with, there are
dozens of very large investment
banks that are trading
securities, currencies,
commodities, derivatives.
Many of these things
are traded on exchanges,
regulated exchanges like NASDAQ
or the New York Stock Exchange.
But up to 40% are actually
traded in unregulated fashion.
They're done in a way that's
called over-the-counter,
meaning that there is no
regulated exchange sitting
in the middle
facilitating these trades.
Instead, the banks,
the entities,
trade amongst themselves in a
slightly more ad hoc fashion.
This represents trillions
of dollars of the economy.
And just to give you
a sense of scale,
the time frequency we're
dealing, with we're not talking
about high-frequency trading.
That's not the use case
that zkLedger is targeting.
We're thinking like
10s of trades a minute.
These are things that
are done electronically.
It's not like people are--
people might be
calling each other up
to arrange these trades,
but oftentimes they're
done electronically.
But we're not considering
high-frequency trading.
So a useful abstraction
for thinking
about a table of these trades
is a transaction ledger.
So each row in the
ledger is a transaction,
transferring assets from
one bank to another.
So this should be very
familiar to everyone.
It looks a little bit different
than things like Bitcoin,
because since this is a ledger
designed for the existing
financial system, we know
who the entities are.
They have names.
They're regulated.
They have companies behind them.
We're not talking just
about arbitrary public keys.
So each row in the
ledger is a transaction.
So here, Citibank is
transferring a million dollars.
So that's another
thing that's very
different than cryptocurrencies.
Here we have multiple
different assets
being recorded in the ledger.
So we're not talking about a
ledger with a native asset,
necessarily.
This is not a cryptocurrency.
Really think about this
like a table in a database
recording transactions.
Those transactions might
be in dollars, or euros,
or municipal bonds, or
securities, or shares--
they could be anything, right?
So we're just
recording transactions.
So Citibank is transferring
a million dollars
to Goldman Sachs.
JP Morgan is transferring
money to UBS and to Barclays.
OK?
So as with
cryptocurrencies, I think,
cryptocurrencies
have inspired people
to reconsider the
case of a distributed
database as a ledger that
multiple entities can write to.
And part of that consideration
involves thinking
about digital signatures.
So maybe these banks have
public, private key pairs.
And perhaps they use their
keys to indicate consent
on the transaction, right?
This is something that's
done under the hood
right now, when you think
about the protocols we
use to exchange data.
But it's not necessarily
done explicitly
when creating these
distributed databases.
So they can use their
keys to attach signatures
to the transaction
to indicate a consent
to transfer for security.
Now, this ledger might be
maintained by a third party,
or it could be a
distributed database,
a permissioned
blockchain that is
run by the transacting parties.
So there are some important
financial invariants
that you want to maintain here
to verify that transactions are
happening correctly, that
they're valid, that assets
aren't created out of nowhere.
So one of them is
consent to transfer.
And we use these
signatures for that.
Another important
thing to verify,
another important invariant,
is that the person
doing the transacting actually
has the assets to transfer.
That they're not making
up assets out of nowhere,
or they're not double-spending--
that there isn't
something incorrect happening.
And then, that assets are
neither created nor destroyed.
That we have
conservation of assets.
So these are important financial
invariants to maintain.
This looks a lot like what
the invariants are that we're
trying to maintain in a
cryptocurrency like Bitcoin
or Ethereum, except this
was with multiple assets,
and we know who the
people are involved.
Now, if this ledger were being
maintained by an exchange,
then the exchange would be
responsible for verifying
and validating that all of
these transactions are correct.
If this ledger is being
maintained by the participants,
it's a permissioned
blockchain, then
everyone can verify and validate
that these invariants are being
maintained by looking
at the blockchain,
by checking the
signatures, right?
So that's great, except
for the fact that privacy
is really, really important.
And quite a bit
of data, and quite
a bit of sensitive
information, is actually
leaked by looking at
these transactions.
So if we want to be able to
maintain financial invariants,
if we want to be able
to check and make sure
that the ledger is correct--
and I mean, this is the
whole point of blockchains,
is that everyone can verify,
and validate, and reconcile
real time.
Then in the act of looking
at those transactions,
you're actually finding out
really sensitive information
about banks' trading
strategy-- about
their intellectual property.
OK?
For example, a large
trade might indicate
that a bank has decided
to get out of a position.
Other banks could
learn about this,
notice it on the
blockchain as they're
validating transactions,
and try to follow suit,
driving down the price.
So privacy, especially
in this type of context,
is really important.
And I'm sure you can imagine
a lot of other different types
of context in which privacy
is important as well, right?
So we don't want to
be in this situation
where we have to
choose between privacy
and being able to
validate what's going on.
Right?
So even if we were to
use a trusted third party
like an exchange,
we still wouldn't
have privacy, necessarily,
because the exchange would
be looking at everything
in the ledger.
So that's the goal here that
we're trying to achieve.
We're trying to
achieve this goal where
we want to be able to
publicly verify and validate
what's happening in the
ledger, and at the same time,
obtain some amount of
privacy for transactions.
We don't want all
transactions to be
public to whoever is
maintaining the ledger,
be that a third party
exchange or a set of banks.
So I'm just going to
pause right there and--
do we get the setup, here?
Privacy versus
verification-- we want both.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was
confused as to how
you verify that people--
transactions are
correct in their
account balances?
It's like there's no
native assets supplied.
NEHA NARULA: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So I have dollars and
euros here, right?
How do you know that Citibank
actually has those dollars
to transfer to Goldman Sachs?
Right?
Where does that come from?
Notice how this is
transaction number 90.
I'm assuming that there's
a transaction up here--
this is just a
subset of the ledger.
But as you'll see
in a moment, we
think about this
role of depositors
who are allowed to deposit
assets into the ledger.
And so I'm assuming there's a
transaction up here somewhere
which in a provable
way shows that someone
we trust to deposit
assets into the ledger
gave Citibank the dollars
necessary for them
to give to Goldman Sachs.
But you're absolutely right.
If the asset isn't
native to the ledger,
then you do have that
connection to the real world,
where you do need to
apply some level of trust.
The question, is it auditable?
Can you at least track
it back up to that point?
Any other questions?
OK, great.
So we want to do the following.
We want to be able to verify
that financial invariants are
maintained, that things
are correct while achieving
privacy.
So one good technique
for achieving privacy
is simply to encrypt or hide the
transactions in the ledger, OK?
So surprisingly, maybe, we
actually know how to do this.
And to, at the same
time, still achieve
checking of the
financial invariants.
Here are two systems that
actually achieve this.
The first is Zerocash, which
was implemented inside of Zcash,
an anonymous cryptocurrency.
In Zcash, transactions
are completely hidden.
They're completely opaque
shielded transactions in Zcash.
Zcash has two transactions.
Once set is public,
like in Bitcoin.
The other set are called
shielded transactions.
And in a shielded
transaction, you
don't know who the parties
are who are involved.
You don't know the amount of
the asset that's transferred.
But you can validate
that this was correct,
that financial invariants
were maintained.
Zerocash and Zcash use a
primitive called zero-knowledge
proofs, and in
particular, zk-SNARKS--
zero knowledge succinct
arguments of knowledge.
Those were actually developed
in part here at MIT.
So using these really
interesting cryptographic
primitives, we're able to
maintain financial invariance
in Zcash.
There's another
system called Solidus,
which is out of Cornell,
which also achieves this.
You can't tell who
the participants are.
And you can still maintain
financial invariants.
Solidus uses a completely
different cryptographic
primitive called PVORM.
So you should check
out both these papers
if you're interested.
It's definitely still possible
to accomplish this, right?
However, there's
still a problem here.
Both of these systems
hide everything.
You get no insight into the
economy, into the blockchain,
into what's actually
happening in the system.
Regulators, in particular,
need insight into markets
in order to maintain
financial stability
and in order to
protect investors.
Even considering
non-financial use cases,
it's oftentimes the
case that people
who might be using a
blockchain, or distributed
ledger, or distributed
database want
to be able to maintain that
certain things are true
and to get some insight into the
system that they're a part of.
Lack of insight can actually
have devastating effects,
as we saw with toxic
assets in 2008.
One part of the problem, one
contributor to the crisis,
was the issue that
people didn't really
have confidence or insight into
exactly what assets banks had
on their books.
It was a bit confusing.
And surprisingly, this
happens to this day
I think there was a case with
Dow Chemical where they didn't
actually know how
many outstanding
shares that they had issued.
They just didn't know.
And they had to
give out a dividend,
and they gave out
too much money or too
little money or
something like that.
So here are some examples
of things that we might
want to measure and understand.
We might want to get a sense
of leverage in the system.
So, the participants
who are holding assets,
how much do they have en masse?
We want to understand exposure.
We might want to get a sense
of market concentration.
It's pretty useful to know
things like, OK, this bank,
this asset in particular is
very highly concentrated.
Or this asset is
more distributed
amongst the participants
of the system.
So there are things
that we might
want to learn about
the economy represented
by the assets in the blockchain.
And that if the entire thing is
encrypted or completely opaque,
we're not going to be able
to really gain this insight.
And toxic assets, like I said.
So here's a specific
example of something
we might want to learn.
Here's a bank.
Here's an auditor.
And the auditor might want to--
let's assume the bank is
using a system like zkLedger,
a permissioned blockchain.
An auditor might
want to know how
exposed is this bank
to a drop in the euro?
So if the euro versus the
dollar changes dramatically,
what's going to happen to
this bank's balance sheet?
So in zkLedger, the
auditor can ask a question
like what fraction of
your assets are in euros?
And the bank might respond,
3 million out of 100 million.
So, 3 million euros,
100 million dollars.
Something like that.
But just simply
asking this question,
the auditor doesn't
really get any assurance
that this answer is correct.
And so this is the
nugget of the problem
that we are trying
to solve and achieve.
So this talk presents zkLedger.
And it's a private,
auditable transaction ledger.
The idea behind zkLedger
is like other systems.
We also hide the transacting
banks and the amounts involved.
We provide integrity
with public verification.
So despite the fact
that you can't really
see the details of
the transaction,
anyone, not just
the participants,
but anyone you want
to show this to,
can publicly verify
and convince themselves
that transactions
are well-formed
and financial invariants
are maintained.
And an auditor can
interactively compute
provably correct
linear functions
over the transactions.
So things like
trying to understand
market concentration, or
leverage, or exposure--
they can compute
a set of queries
over the contents of the
transactions in the ledger.
OK, so I'm going to describe
to you how zkLedger works.
I'm going to give you a brief
overview of the system model.
And then I'm going
to start to go
into some of the more
interesting pieces
inside zkLedger.
So the commitments
that we use to hide
things, the way the
ledger is constructed.
And I'm going to
tell you a little bit
about the primitives
that we use,
which are zero-knowledge proofs.
Not SNARKs, which I talked
about earlier-- a different type
of zero-knowledge proof.
But I'll give you a
little bit of a flavor
of what those things look like.
And then I'll show you the
performance of zkLedger.
So whether you buy
this use case or not,
I think that you will
see these topics come
up over and over again as you're
looking at cryptocurrencies.
People are quite interested
in zero-knowledge proofs
and how they can use
them to provide privacy
inside of cryptocurrencies.
OK, before we jump into the
system model, any questions?
OK, let's go.
So let's start with
the system model.
So here's the system model.
We have a set of banks.
These banks have generated
public keys and secret keys,
which they have.
And these banks are working
together to construct a ledger.
And the way that
this ledger works
is that they are
determining transactions
amongst themselves.
So they're deciding, OK, I'm
going to transfer this amount
to that bank.
And then once they've
decided on a transaction,
they append that
transaction to the ledger.
And again, remember,
this ledger could
be maintained by a third party.
It could be maintained
by the banks themselves
on a blockchain.
They could be using a
public bulletin board.
They could be posting
transactions to Twitter.
It doesn't matter.
We're not really concerned
about that right now.
The point is that there is
an append-only ledger that's
orthogonal to our techniques--
how exactly it's maintained.
An auditor, a third
party auditor,
can obtain correct
answers to questions
based on ledger contents.
So note that auditing
is interactive.
It's not the case that someone
can just take this ledger
and compute things over it.
They can't do that.
There's not enough
information here
to reveal the
answers to queries.
The auditor has to actually
talk to the participants
in the ledger.
So you might say,
well, we didn't
trust the participants to give
the auditor the right answer.
Why would we trust them to
answer the auditor at all?
Well in the setting
that we've set up
for ourselves, if they
don't answer the auditor,
they can go to jail.
OK?
So at least you can tell whether
the bank is answering you
or not.
If the bank were to lie to you,
you might not be able to tell
whether-- this allows
you to be able to--
if you get an answer, you know
that that answer is correct.
So the auditor
will query the bank
and ask a question
similar to what
we were asking before--
what fraction of your assets
are in euros?
The bank can respond.
But this time, instead of
just getting an answer,
the auditor also gets a small
part of a proof from the bank
and can confirm that
that proof is correct
based on these
opaque transaction
details in the ledger.
So the auditor still
needs to talk to the bank,
but using the bank's
response, they
can compute a proof that
shows that this answer must
be correct.
OK?
So auditing is interactive.
Like I said, it's
possible a bank
might choose not to respond.
That could happen.
Also I want to point out that
if the auditor is constantly
auditing this ledger--
is constantly asking how
many euros do you have?
How many euros do you have?
Then if that number
changes, it's
reasonable to assume
that that change happened
in the last transaction
appended to the ledger.
Right?
So if the bank
continually answers
the auditor's questions, this
will leak transaction contents.
This doesn't provide what's
known as differential privacy.
OK?
And so the setup here is
that the auditor and the bank
should come to some agreement
about the appropriate level
of frequency of auditing such
that both the auditor gets
the data that they need, and
the bank maintains the privacy
that it needs to maintain.
OK, so as I said
before, zkLedger
supports any linear function
over transaction values.
So we can do ratios,
sums, averages, variance,
skews outliers.
By outliers, I mean give me
all the transactions that have
amounts outside of this range.
So you want all high-value
transactions, you can provably,
correctly give that.
Approximation-- so orders
of magnitude of my trades,
without revealing
the precise number.
Changes over time, and also
well-known financial risk
measurements like the
Herfindahl-Hirschman Index.
So in this talk--
oh, sorry.
Yes, there are small amounts
of well-defined leakage
for some of these measurements.
So for example, in order
to compute the average,
we actually compute the sum
and the number of transactions.
So we leak a little
bit more information
than just the average, but
it's very well-defined.
And in this talk,
I'm only really going
to talk about sums.
But our paper, which I'll put
a point or two on the website,
explains how to do
more complex things.
And everything's built
on the sums primitive.
So let's talk about
the security goals.
So what are we trying to
achieve with the system?
So first of all, we're
trying to achieve privacy.
We want to make sure that
the auditor and non-involved
parties cannot see transaction
participants or amounts.
So I don't know if I
made this clear before,
but it's not just the case
that this third-party auditor
can't see who's in transactions
or what they're transacting.
Anyone who's not
actually involved
in the transaction,
receiving or sending assets,
also can't see inside
of a transaction.
Completeness.
So what do we mean
by completeness?
What we mean by that is that
banks can't lie to the auditor.
They can't say that they have
5 million euros when actually
they have 3 million euros.
But also, the bank can't
selectively leave out things.
OK?
So you could imagine
some ways of constructing
this in which, if a
bank was really clever,
they could just not include
some of the transactions
that they had received,
and thus change
their answers to the auditor.
But one of our security
goals that we achieve
is that it's impossible for
a bank to omit transactions
when responding to the auditor.
We also are looking
to achieve integrity,
so banks can't violate
financial invariants.
We assume that
banks are malicious.
But honest banks
should always be
able to convince the
auditor of a correct answer.
So we don't want to
have a situation where
a malicious bank screws
up the ledger such
that an honest bank can't
respond to the auditor
because the ledger
doesn't make sense.
So we also want
to maintain that.
And then progress.
We also want to make sure that
a malicious bank can't block
other banks from transacting--
that they can't hold up
the entire ledger.
And I think as I
describe the design,
it'll become clearer why
these things were issues
that we were worried about.
And it's part of how
we designed the system
to address these problems.
So, the threat model.
And the threat model
describes what kind
of attacks that we are
trying to protect against
and what kind of attacks
we don't protect against.
So banks might attempt
to steal or hide
assets, manipulate balances,
or lie to the auditor.
Banks can arbitrarily
collude, so they
can try to work together
to do these things.
And banks or the
auditor might try
to learn transaction contents.
So it's not that
they're passive.
They might actually be
trying to actively learn
what's happening in the ledger.
What's out of
scope for this work
is a ledger that omits
transactions or is unavailable.
As I said, we're agnostic
to the ledger implementation
as long as it's available
so it accepts transactions.
If the ledger doesn't
accept transactions,
we can't provide our goals.
We also don't protect against
an adversary who might
be watching network traffic.
So if there's an adversary
who's snooping on the network
and sees that two banks
are communicating a lot,
it's reasonable to assume that
those two banks are involved
in all the transactions.
There are other techniques
to deal with these problems.
And then also
what's out of scope
is banks leaking their
own transactions.
If a bank leaks their
own transactions,
we throw up our hands.
Sorry, we tried to
give you privacy.
So that's the system
model for zkLedger.
That's the threat model,
those are our goals, that's
what we're trying to achieve.
Now, let's get into the
design a little bit.
So we're going to build up the
design based on this example.
So here is an example of a
public transaction ledger.
And we're going to slowly start
to mask things in this ledger
until we end up with
zkLedger's design.
So we have four
transactions here.
I'm only using one asset, euros.
You'll notice that the
first transaction addresses
the question that you
asked, which is, well,
where do funds come from?
And here we have a
special depositor,
who is injecting
assets into the system.
This depositor might be the
central bank, for example.
A lot of systems are
actually designed this way.
So Stellar, I think Chains,
Blockchain, Ripple--
these systems are all
designed with the idea
of a special depositor
who's allowed
to create their own asset and
insert it into the system.
So here, maybe the depositor
is the European Central Bank.
Maybe it's some other
bank, who provably has
a lot of euros in their account
and puts them onto the ledger.
So there's a depositor who's
granting 30 million euros
to Goldman Sachs.
And then there are
three transactions.
And I think it's important
to get a sense of what
these transactions are.
So Goldman Sachs is transferring
10 million to JP Morgan.
And then JP Morgan, in two
different transactions,
is transferring
money to Barclays.
OK?
So let's move on from here.
So like I said, the depositor
injects assets to ledger,
and that's the way of
entering transactions.
That's the depositor,
right there.
Now our goals are to achieve
auditing and privacy.
What do we mean by that?
Well, we shouldn't-- someone
looking at the ledger
shouldn't be able to
tell these amounts except
for the depositor transaction,
which is always public.
In zkLedger, the depositor
transactions are public.
But they shouldn't be
able to tell after that
that Goldman Sachs gave
money to JP Morgan,
and that JP Morgan
gave it to Barclays,
and what the amounts were.
OK?
So in this example, we're
going to try to provably audit
Barclays to figure out how
many euros Barclays is holding.
And again, we want to hide
the participants, amounts,
and the transaction graph.
So what do I mean when
I say transaction graph?
I think you guys learned a
little bit about a system
called confidential
transactions a few weeks ago.
Confidential transactions does
not hide the transaction graph.
It hides the
amounts, but you can
tell the source of the funds.
So here, the money
that Barclays got--
so if we were trying to attain
privacy in the system, the fact
that Goldman Sachs got
euros, and Goldman Sachs is
the only company that
got euros, is public,
because depositor
transactions are public.
But we shouldn't be able
to tell that the euros
that Barclays got--
obviously they must have been
sourced through Goldman Sachs.
We shouldn't be able to tell
they went through anyone,
or how many people
they went through,
or that it was JP Morgan.
So if we leaked the
transaction graph,
you might be able
to tell that there
was an entity that
the money went through
before it got to Barclays.
So when we say we want to
hide the transaction graph,
that's what we mean.
We want to be able to hide
the flow of funds, how
they move through the system.
We hide the amounts by using a
cryptographic primitive called
Pedersen commitments.
So Pedersen commitments,
as you learned,
are binding and hiding
commitments to a value.
And the way that they work--
and I'm terribly sorry, but I
use slightly different notation
than Tadge.
So Tadge uses
additive notation--
multiplicative notation, and
I use exponential notation.
These mean exactly
the same thing.
I will very quickly
write down what they are.
So in Tadge's notation, G and
H are generators in some group.
And if you have some
value and some randomness,
then you would write a Pedersen
commitment as that, OK?
Now, whether it's r times G,
or v times H isn't important.
The point is these are
two generators of a group,
in this case, an
elliptical curve group.
And in Bitcoin, secp256k1.
It doesn't really matter
what those generators are.
You just pick any two.
You could call this G1
and G2, if you wanted to.
And so this is the way
that Tadge would write it.
The way that I write it--
and I'm sorry about
this, but it's good
that you guys get
exposed to both ways,
because you'll find both
ways in the literature--
is in exponential notation.
So I would write g
to the v, h to the r.
And they're multiplied together
instead of added together.
OK?
So this is just purely
a notational thing.
It's just, instead of the
multiply operator here,
we're doing exponentiation.
Instead of the
plus operator here,
we're doing multiplication.
So, Pedersen commitment.
The way that you
commit to a value v
is everyone has chosen
these generators.
The generator choice
is system-wide.
This isn't something
you pick at the time you
make a transaction.
The generator choice
is system-wide.
However, the r, the randomness,
you do choose fresh each time.
You pick any
randomness each time.
And the way that you
commit to a value
is by producing this
value right here,
which is the generator
raised to the value
times the second generator
raised to the randomness.
And what this serves
to do is it's binding.
It's very difficult to
come up with, later,
a different and a
different r that ends up
equaling the same commitment.
And part of that is
based on an assumption
called the discrete
logarithm-- the hardness
of the discrete
logarithm problem.
And also, importantly,
these things
can be homomorphically combined.
So if we have these commitments
to these different values,
and we multiply
them together, well,
when you multiply things that
are raised to an exponent,
you end up adding
the exponent, right?
So by multiplying
these things together,
we end up with a
valid commitment
to the sum of the values in
the individual commitments
that we multiplied together.
So we can homomorphically
combine the commitments.
It ends up summing
in the exponent.
And we end up with
a valid commitment
to the sum of the values.
Another nice property
of Pedersen commitments
is that they are very fast to
create, combine, and verify.
And perhaps surprisingly,
we can actually
achieve all of the
auditing functions
that I showed you earlier just
using Pedersen commitments.
So before we move on, questions
on Pedersen commitments?
I know that you guys learned
about this in a previous class,
but they're pretty important.
They're used in
confidential transactions
as well to prove that
the sum of the outputs
is less than or equal to
the sum of the inputs,
if you guys recall that.
So any questions?
AUDIENCE: When are you
making this commitment?
NEHA NARULA: Ah, great question.
You're making this
commitment at the time
that the transaction is created.
And I'll get into the details
of who creates the transaction,
and what do they choose,
and how does that happen,
and how do we make sure
they don't screw it up.
AUDIENCE: So when you add a
measurement to this ledger,
it might add a number of
commitments that people make...
NEHA NARULA: Well,
so measurements
happen on top of the ledger.
So we can actually do
all of our measurements
basically just on
those commitments.
We don't have to add
anything to ledger.
OK.
So, yes, like I said, we
can achieve all the auditing
functions with
Pedersen commitments.
And I'll go into a
little bit of detail.
OK, great.
So we can use Pearson
commitments to hide the value.
So again, by using these
commitments, you can't--
looking at this right
here, if you don't know r,
you can't guess--
if you don't know v
and r, you can't--
if you don't know r, you
can't guess what v is.
It could be anything.
So that's what we mean when we
say that these commitments are
perfectly hiding.
So we also want to
hide the participants
in the transaction, obviously.
And we're going to do that
using other techniques.
Just hold that in your
head for a moment.
We're going to jump to that.
But first, quickly,
let's take a look
at how auditing might work given
that we're using these Pedersen
commitments, OK?
So assume that we have hidden
who the participants are
in this ledger
through a technique
that I'm not telling
you about, yet.
We're hiding the values in
the transactions that are not
inject-- not these
special transactions that
are injecting assets or removing
assets, but just the transfers.
We're hiding the values using
Pedersen commitments, OK?
So let's look at how
auditing might work.
So an auditor will
ask the bank--
in this case, it's Barclays.
So remember, Barclays
received euros
in two different
transactions, and should
tell the auditor 3 million.
The auditor asks Barclays,
how many euros do you hold?
Barclays can convince the
auditor that 3 million
is the right answer by
doing the following.
OK?
Barclays can say, hey,
auditor, it's 3 million.
OK.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to actually open up the
combined commitments
for my transactions.
So I don't actually have
this on a slide here,
but I will write
out what this means.
OK?
So we have two transactions
here and two commitments.
And one of them is
g to the 1 million,
h to-- the let's just r1.
And then the other is g to
the 2 million, h to the r2.
OK?
These are the commitments
in the ledger.
Barclays wants to
convince the auditor
that it has 3 million euros.
It does so by-- when you
multiply these two things
together, and the auditor can't
see what these two things are,
but this is--
or actually, I
think it's comm 2--
3.
OK, comm 3 times comm 4.
Then when you multiply
these two things together,
you get g to the 1 million plus
2 million h to the r1 plus r2,
OK?
This is 3 million.
If Barclays gives the auditor
3 million and r1 plus r2,
the sum, than the
auditor can confirm
that if they raise g to this
and h to this, that it's
equal to the
multiplication of the two
commitments on the ledger.
And the auditor can--
given that these two
things are equal,
then the auditor knows
that the bank in fact
did commit to two commitments
that sum to $3 million.
It doesn't know if that was 1.5
and 1.5, or 1 and 2 million,
999--
it doesn't know what those
individual values were.
It just knows that
the sum is correct.
So, questions about
opening commitments?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The sub-3,
sub-4-- those are the IDs?
NEHA NARULA: Yeah,
those are 3 and 4.
Sorry, I'm using
different numbers.
They're r1 and r2.
But the comm 3 and comm 4 are--
this is literally a
elliptic curve point.
So the point is
posted to the ledger.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't 4 million and
minus 1 million also do that?
NEHA NARULA: It would, yes.
And we'll talk about
how we address that.
AUDIENCE: So just
to confirm, the bank
provides both the 3
million number and--
NEHA NARULA: And r1 plus r2.
Yes.
And those two pieces
of information
are enough to convince
the auditor that 3 million
does in fact correspond to
the commitments on the ledger.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
so you will always
get the sum and the
number of transactions?
NEHA NARULA: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You will get the
number of transactions?
NEHA NARULA: Who's you?
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE]
as in the auditor.
NEHA NARULA: The
auditor will get--
AUDIENCE: They will know
the number of transactions?
NEHA NARULA: In the straw
man example that I've done,
it does look that way, yes.
I'm going to build up to
how the auditor won't know
the number of transactions.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So as a
user, you are recording
all of your randomness?
You're responsible for tracking
NEHA NARULA: You're responsible
for tracking your randomness.
And you're responsible
for tracking
your own individual details.
You have to keep that
in your own databases.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If somebody
found your randomness--
NEHA NARULA: If someone
found your randomnesses,
then they could guess--
they could backwards-compute
the values of your transactions.
Yes.
OK.
AUDIENCE: How do you
define the timing?
NEHA NARULA: The time--
getting to that.
So we'll get to that.
So just in figures,
showing what we did there.
The auditor can look at
those two commitments,
compute the product
for themselves,
and confirm that this 3 million
lines up with what they see.
However, this has
the problem that it
reveals the transactions
in which Barclays
was involved, right?
Barclays is saying, hey,
multiply these two things
together, right?
And not only that,
Barclays could lie.
OK?
Barclays could
say, oh, actually,
I only have 1 million euros.
Here's the transaction
that proves
that I have 1 million euros.
I will just give you our one.
I will just point
to this transaction.
Don't worry about the
other transactions.
I'm not involved in them.
The bank, Barclays,
could leave out
relevant important transactions
in this straw man design.
OK?
And importantly, this
would match up, right?
The auditor would say,
OK, you've given me--
Barclays could just give--
could leave this
part out entirely.
Could just give
1 million and r1,
and the auditor
would say, why, yes,
that does match up
to commitment three.
Great.
Good work.
And they wouldn't
even know that there
was another commitment
out there that they
should be concerned about.
So how do we address
this problem?
And this, I think,
was the key insight
in the design of our system.
In zkLedger, a
transaction actually
has a commitment for every
participant in the system.
So let's talk about
that for a second.
So depositor transactions
still basically look the way
that they did before
they're public.
But transfer transactions
now look quite different.
We don't actually have the
names of the participant
in the transaction.
The names are implied by the
values of the commitments
in that participants column.
So now we're looking
at a transaction
as a row with multiple columns.
And there's a column per
participant in the system.
If a bank is not involved
in the transaction at all,
then their commitment
is to the value 0.
If the bank is involved
in a transaction,
and it's doing the
spending, then its value--
sorry, depositor transactions.
Yes.
If a bank is involved
in the transaction,
it's doing the spending, it
commits to a negative value.
And if it's doing the
receiving, it commits--
sorry, not it, but the
creator of the transaction,
commits to a positive value.
So the way that you transfer
$1 million from one bank
to another is committing to a
negative value in the spenders
column-- here, JP Morgan--
and committing to a positive
value in the receivers column--
here, Barclays.
And again for non-involved
banks, entries commit to 0.
But one thing I want to stress--
commitments to 0 are completely
indistinguishable from
commitments to any other value.
And commitments
to negative values
are indistinguishable from
commitments to positive values.
So someone looking at this, just
looking at these commitments
posted to the ledger, has
no idea which ones are 0s,
and which ones are negative,
and which ones are positive.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this
mean that each bank has
to keep track of
every transaction that
is done in the ledger, and
produce the random numbers,
and keep track of
those numbers, too?
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
So, yeah, one design
might have it be the case
that every bank
actually has to be
involved in every transaction.
We managed to design zkLedger
so that the spending bank can
produce one of these
without actually involving
any of the other banks.
And I will describe
how that happens.
OK, and so, given
now that we've said,
essentially, every bank is
involved in every transaction,
this actually makes life
easier for the auditor.
Because now when the
auditor audits a bank,
they audit every transaction.
So they audit the entire
column for a bank.
So here, when the auditor
is auditing Barclays,
they won't just look at whatever
transactions Barclays tells
them to look at.
They will look at
every transaction.
OK?
And this is where--
I think someone
asked about timing,
or how do you audit a
range of transactions?
The auditor can actually
tell the bank, oh, I just
want to audit from
this point onwards.
Or it can say, I
just want to audit
your transactions for the
past month, if it wants to.
That doesn't mean that Barclays
can leave out transactions,
because there's supposed to
be a time stamp column in here
as well.
So you can see when
transactions happen.
That's public.
So what happens
here is the auditor
is going to look at everything.
They're actually going to
multiply three commitments
together, because there's three
commitments in that column.
And it doesn't know which ones
are 0 and which ones are not 0.
But the 0 doesn't
contribute to the sum.
And so a malicious bank can't
actually lie to the auditor,
because in this
case, the bank is not
going to leave out
commitment four.
And in fact, it's also going
to include commitment two.
So the bank is going to have
to include the r primes in here
to get all of this to
work out correctly.
It's going to have to
include everything.
So this next--
I'm actually going to
skip a little bit of this,
because I think we're
running a bit low on time.
And I do want to get into
what the proofs look like.
So I'm going to skip
this averages part.
I'm going to go back
to our security goals.
What I just described to you,
the ledger table construction,
allows us to achieve our
first two security goals.
Privacy-- because these
commitments are perfectly
hiding, no one can see
transaction participants.
They can't tell who's
committing to 0,
and who's not committing to 0.
Banks can't lie to the auditor,
because the auditor audits
every transaction for a bank.
But what I haven't
figured out yet
is, well, how do we maintain
financial invariants
in this scheme?
How do we make sure assets
aren't created out of nowhere?
How do we make sure that
whoever is spending actually
consented to the spend?
And how do we construct
this transaction
that involves every bank when
we assume banks are malicious,
and we don't want one bank to
be able to hold up everyone
from transacting?
So our solution to do
that is to use a set
of what are called NIZKs--
non-interactive
zero-knowledge proofs.
So what are NIZKs?
NIZKs are short binary strings.
True statements have proofs.
So, if a statement is true,
it should have a proof
indicating that it's true.
False statements
only have proofs
with negligible probability.
And proofs don't reveal
why they are true.
So we're going to use
NIZKs to prove things
like the person who knows the
secret key for this public key
consented to this transfer,
without indicating which
bank it was that
consented to the transfer.
We're going to use
NIZKs to prove things
like this bank has
the assets to spend,
without revealing how many
assets that bank actually has.
So zkLedger uses a set of
carefully crafted NIZKs.
And to be clear,
NIZKs are pretty old.
They were invented in
the '80s and the '90s.
And most of them are
based on the hardness
of the discrete log problem in
elliptic curve cryptography,
again.
So here are the
properties we want
to achieve with transactions.
We want transaction validity.
We want to make sure whoever
is the spender, whoever
has a negative amount
in their column,
actually consented
to the transfer.
And again, remember, in
cryptocurrencies and things
like that, where it's OK to
reveal who the person is who's
spending, we use a signature.
In this case, we'll use proof
of knowledge of secret key.
So there's a consent NIZK.
We want to be able to prove that
whoever is spending actually
has the assets to
transfer-- that they're not
going negative.
And we use an assets NIZK.
And we want to make sure that
assets are neither created
nor destroyed, so for that
we use a balance NIZK.
We want to show that
things work out,
and you didn't create more
euros than you were supposed to.
The only place where
you can do that
is in the depositor
transactions,
the public depositor
transactions.
We also want to make sure that
honest banks can make progress.
And in order to do that,
creating a transaction
in zkLedger is non-interactive.
The banks don't have to interact
to create a transaction.
This is exactly how systems
like Ethereum and Bitcoin work,
if you think about it.
I can't stop you from
sending me Bitcoin, right?
If you want to send
me Bitcoin, you
construct a transaction
that sends me Bitcoin.
You submit it to the blockchain.
I have nothing to do with that.
Offline, we might have
agreed that the reason you're
sending me Bitcoin is
because I'm selling you
my car or something like that.
But to actually create the
transaction that spends,
you don't have to talk to
the other participants.
And we use a consistency NIZK
so that the person creating
the transaction can prove
in a publicly verifiable way
that everything
matches up correctly,
that all of these
proofs are correct,
and that all of the banks
are going to be able to later
respond to the auditor--
be able to respond to
the auditor as necessary.
So to give you a
little bit of insight
into why this consistency
NIZK is necessary,
over here, I was speaking
as though the bank knew
all of the r values, right?
Actually, in zkLedger,
if a bank is not
involved in a transaction,
if their commitment's to 0,
they don't know
their own r value,
because some other
bank has created that.
So if we go backwards
a little bit to here,
Barclays wasn't involved
in this transaction at all.
And in fact, Barclays--
so Goldman Sachs
created this transaction.
JP Morgan created
this one and this one.
Barclays had nothing
to do with them.
They weren't involved at all.
And we can't assume
that Barclays knows
what the rs are in its column.
Yet the way that I
told you that Barclays'
response to the auditor is by
revealing the sum of the rs.
So that's actually not
how zkLedger works.
They don't actually
reveal the sum of the rs.
The proof is a little
bit more complicated.
The rs are encoded
for Barclays in a way
that it can't see what they
are, but it can use them.
And the consistency proof is
to prove that that encoding was
done correctly.
So again, you can see
the paper for details,
but I'm actually
going to tell you
a little bit about these proofs
and what they look like, OK?
So, consent.
The consent proof is proof of
knowledge of secret key, sk.
So what this means is that if
the value in the commitment
in this entry is
negative, then there
should be a proof of
knowledge of secret key
to indicate that this bank
has consented to subtracting
from their assets.
Also, if the value
is negative, you
need to create a
proof of assets.
Technically, you don't
need a proof of assets
if the value is not
negative, but we're
trying not to reveal,
remember, which bank is
involved in which transaction.
So I'm going to draw
a transaction up
here and explain a
little bit about where
these proofs actually go.
A transaction is a row.
And there is an entry for
each bank in the transaction.
So there is a commitment.
So let's-- negative 1 million.
And then there is also
these sets of proofs.
So, proof of assets,
in particular.
And every single entry
has a proof of assets,
even though, really, this
is the only bank that's
spending and needs to
prove that it has assets.
The proof of assets is
constructed to look like this.
It's a new commitment,
either to the sum
of the values in the
column, or, if you're not
the spending bank, a
commitment to the value.
And it also includes
a proof that the value
in this auxiliary
commitment is in range.
So what do I mean by that?
I think you guys should have
covered this in the Pedersen
commitment lecture with
confidential transactions,
but when you're dealing
with cyclic groups,
you can wrap around
the end of the group.
And that's the same as if
you hadn't wrapped around.
There are many
different things that
can occupy one point in the
space of a cyclic group.
So we need to include
proofs that your value is
in a range that's expected.
And in the case of
zkLedger, we need
to prove that the
value is between 0
and a certain upper
limit that is less
than the order of the group.
And we use the
exact same technique
that they use in confidential
transactions to do this--
borromean ring signatures.
What's kind of exciting is
that, a few months ago, there
was some work done on a faster,
smaller, more aggregatable
version of range proofs using
a system called bullet proofs.
So as you'll see
in the evaluation,
this sounds like such
a silly little thing.
Oh, yeah, also prove that
the value is in range.
This is like 90% of all of the
space and work in zkLedger.
These range proofs are
the bane of our existence.
They take up a lot of space.
They're very slow to create and
verify, but they're necessary.
So making them faster is
a really amazing thing.
Then the next thing is balance.
And I think this
one is illustrative,
because it shows that a proof--
sometimes you have a
proof not by creating
an additional binary string,
but by the way you choose
things in your transaction.
So the way that you prove
that no funds are created
or destroyed is as follows.
So these are-- remember these
commitments are g to the 0.
Let's say h the r1, g to
the negative 1 million,
h to the r2, and g to the
1 million, h to the r3.
Now, given that we
have these commitments,
how can we prove to
someone that no assets
were created or destroyed?
Well, what does it
mean for no assets
to be created or destroyed?
It means that the sum of
the vs is equal to 0, right?
That's what it
means for no assets
to be created or destroyed.
How can we prove to someone
that, given that all they're
seeing are these commitments,
that the sum of the vs
commit to 0?
Well, let's just make the sum
of the rs also commit to 0.
So if the sum of the rs
also commits to 0, then
when you multiply
these things together,
you're going to get g
to the sum of the vs, h
to the sum of the rs.
And if both of these things
are 0, you get g to the 0,
h to the 0, which
should equal what?
One, exactly.
So we choose our
rs very carefully,
so that the auditor, or
whoever is verifying this,
can just multiply all the
commitments together and verify
that they equal 1.
And if it equals
1, that means it
would have been very difficult
to choose vs such that you
could make this come out to 1
without it actually coming out
to 1.
So that's the proof of balance.
It's not an actual proof.
It's not a short binary string.
It's literally choosing the
exponents in a clever way
to show that we can maintain
the invariant that we want.
Does that make sense?
Questions about these proofs?
And I didn't go into
proof of assets very much.
It's the most complicated one.
But you can check out the paper.
I see some confused faces.
You don't have to
ask about the proofs.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you just
choose both of the exponents?
So if you're choosing
rs in a certain way,
can't you choose
them in a certain way
and then choose payments
so that they sum to 0?
NEHA NARULA: Well,
we're trying to prove
that the payments sum to 0.
That's what we want.
Because that means that assets
weren't created or destroyed.
And remember--
AUDIENCE: You're
generating-- you're
creating those random numbers
in a way that they sum to zero.
So if you create them in a
way that doesn't sum to 0?
NEHA NARULA: Then
every-- ah, OK.
So this is an important--
AUDIENCE: Change
the transaction so
that the sum of the rs and the
sum of the values sum to 0?
NEHA NARULA: So basically,
what you're saying--
I think what you're say--
OK, you could be saying
one of two things.
Number one, what if you
choose your vs and rs such
that it doesn't sum to 0, right?
What if you produce an
invalid transaction?
And the answer is that
everyone will reject it.
Sort of similar
to Bitcoin, if you
don't have a valid
transaction, good for you.
But it's going to be
considered invalid by everyone
in the system.
And everyone's going to
skip it and ignore it.
It's not going to be part
of what happens, right?
So this is part of
the proof of validity
that all of the participants
have consented to.
The second question
you might be asking
is, what if these
don't sum to 0,
but I still manage
to figure out how
to make this equal 1, right?
That's what you-- OK, so that's
the question you're asking.
Based on the assumption that
the discrete logarithm problem
is hard--
this is too hard to figure out.
You literally cannot find--
there is an assumption here.
These are two generators
of the group, right?
So that means the g is
equal to h to the x,
that there's some way
to produce one generator
from the other generator.
There is an assumption here
that figuring out what that x is
is nearly impossible.
So you don't know what
g is in terms of h.
And given that you don't know
this relationship between g
and h, you can't figure
out how to produce
two exponents that sum to
what you want them to sum to.
So is the hardness problem that
these systems are based on.
If you could do that,
if you could figure out
a sum of rs such that it
gave you a 1 with the vs
you wanted, then you would
have broken the discrete log
problem.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So who
chooses the [INAUDIBLE]
we know that they don't know the
relationship [INAUDIBLE] they
maliciously gave those two?
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
So the answer is
that in our system,
the way that we choose g and
h is by taking the SHA-256
hash of 0 and 1.
Those are numbers such that--
they're sufficiently
random, and they
show that if you took
a hash of 0 and 1,
you would have no relationship
between those two.
And everyone uses the same g and
h, right, from the beginning.
Any other questions?
OK, so we're
running low on time,
but I do want to go through
the evaluation really
quickly, because--
so this system, this paper,
was presented at NSDI
in April, which is a
systems conference.
And I think part of the reason
that the systems community
liked it was because
it's surprisingly fast.
You might have heard that
computing unencrypted data is
too slow.
It's infeasible.
You can't do it.
Well, the answer is,
actually, if you understand
the set of computations
you want to do really well,
you can structure things
using things like these NIZKs
and the discrete log
problem in such a way
that you can do that computation
actually pretty fast.
So zkLedger is written in Go.
It uses an elliptic
curve as the group--
secp256k1, which is
the same elliptic curve
that Bitcoin uses.
We use range proofs to
prevent overflow, like I said.
We use the same ones as in
confidential transactions
and confidential assets.
And it's around
4,000 lines of code.
It's mostly
cryptography functions.
We don't actually
implement our own ledger,
because we're ledger agnostic.
So in the evaluation we
want to understand how fast
is auditing, first of all?
Right?
And then second,
the construction
I described to you,
you might think
is very slow, because
every bank has
an entry in every transaction.
So how does this actually
work in practice?
Can we get away with
such a construction?
So first, let's talk
about the auditing.
Auditing is really fast.
So here, we are
auditing four banks,
and we're doing a
measurement called
the Herfindahl-Hirschman
Index, so we're
trying to understand market
concentration for a given
asset.
And what's happening
here is the auditor
is keeping up with the ledger
and keeping these things
that we call commitment caches.
So because of the
design of our system
and the fact that we're using
these Pedersen commitments--
which, we can actually
maintain rolling sums
going down of these
commitments and use them
when needing to
answer the auditor
or confirm that a bank
has the correct answer.
And so this means that auditing
for banks is milliseconds.
It's a few milliseconds
to audit the banks.
And we see here on the x-axis we
have the number of transactions
in the ledger.
The reason that
auditing a bank is
independent of the number of
transactions in the ledger
is because of these
commitment caches.
We can do it really fast,
assuming an online auditor
who's keeping up with things.
And part of the reason for
that is because of our design.
It's very amenable to caching.
Now, if the auditor is
not online and hasn't
been maintaining
commitment caches,
then auditing is order the
number of things in the ledger.
Here, we have a ledger
with 100,000 entries.
It takes about 3.5
seconds to audit that.
Still not so bad, really.
And it's pretty linear, so
you could imagine, well,
if you had a million entries,
it would be 10 times that.
It would be about 30 seconds.
Still pretty
reasonable, actually.
A question some
people ask is, well,
do we have to maintain
this ledger forever?
How do you clean up the ledger?
You can create a snapshot
of the state in the ledger
and get rid of
the past, assuming
you know the set
of auditing queries
that you're going to
do moving forward.
We don't implement this,
but this should be possible.
Right, so if you wanted
to do 100 million rows,
it would work out
to be about an hour.
So here is a graph
which shows how long it
takes to create and verify
transactions in zkLedger.
And this is varying
the number of banks.
And again, we see
this is linear.
The more banks, the more
entries per transaction,
the more of these commitments,
the more range proofs,
quite honestly, is the problem.
Because there's a
range proof per entry.
And what we see here
is that with 10 banks,
it's about a second
or 800 milliseconds
to create a transaction,
which is not unreasonable.
Again, this achieves the
multiple per second things
we were looking for, depending
on the number of banks.
However, it is
linear in the number
of participants in the system.
So something like this is not
really suitable for a setting
like Bitcoin, where there are
thousands, if not millions,
of participants in the system.
This graph gives you an
idea of how all of that cost
breaks down.
So these are the
components in the proofs.
And again, I think the
thing to get from here
is that range proofs are
the entirety of the problem.
So this is the number in a
transaction for k participants.
So this is each slot.
There are two
different commitments.
The first commitment, and
then the auxiliary commitment.
There's two different
consistency proofs.
There's a disjunctive proof,
and there's a range proof.
And yeah, the commitment is
one elliptic curve point,
which in Go is a big int--
two big ints.
And so that's 64 bytes.
This is something that is
actually highly compressable.
We didn't actually-- oh, OK.
Yeah, I'll get to that
point in a moment.
But note here that the range
proofs are slower and larger
than everything else combined.
They are the entirety of
the cost of the system.
So a faster way of doing range
proofs would really help a lot.
It would make us be able to
handle many, many more banks.
So this is the cost
in a transaction
per participant in the system.
[AUDIO OUT] One thing
that I want to point out
is that this is all very
highly parallelizable.
And like I said, we're using
Go's big int construction,
which is not really
very optimized at all.
So I think that there are
a lot of opportunities
to make this faster.
So I think if we put in
some engineering legwork,
we could create a
system that was maybe
twice as fast as what we have
now, and could handle maybe 100
banks.
So really quickly to
wrap up, related work.
If you're interested
in this topic,
there's a lot of different
papers to read about and study.
This is all-- confidential
assets kicked off
this line of using Pedersen
commitments for privacy
in cryptocurrencies.
Zerocash was the origin
of using zk-SNARKs.
They don't really support
auditing in any fashion.
Then there's a couple papers
that are really interesting,
one from Andrew
Lowe, actually, who's
in the economics
department here at MIT,
on using secure
multi-party computation
to attack this problem.
The issue with
that sort of design
is that it doesn't actually
have the completeness guarantee
that we have.
So if the ledger really
represents the assets
in the system, and the assets
that you're trying to audit,
then there's no way
for a participant
to lie in a multi-party
computation.
They can use the wrong inputs.
So those systems
provide secrecy,
but they don't
provide completeness.
And then I mentioned
Solidus before,
which I think our techniques
would apply to really nicely.
And then there's
a paper, a design
for doing some other sorts
of accountability stuff
with cryptocurrencies, like
proving you paid your taxes,
or proving that money didn't go
through some blacklisted thing
using zk-SNARKs.
But that's not really a
system, it's a design.
But I think that's also a really
promising area to consider.
So, future work.
We want to consider more
applications besides just
large investment banks
trading securities and assets.
Can we do something
with clinical trials?
with supply chains?
I think that these
techniques can
be applied to a lot more areas.
And I'd love to
hear from you guys
if you have ideas on that, or
if you're interested in working
on that and want to do
a UROP, or maybe even
an M.Eng., that's definitely
something that's on the table.
We get surprisingly far
with Pedersen commitments,
but if we included
more interesting types
of cryptographic primitives,
we could probably
get more functionality.
So what's the type--
we know, given
that we might want to apply this
to different use cases, what
types of functionality
might we need?
There's someone at
the Media Lab here
who is interested in running
algorithms on research trials.
And secrecy and privacy
is really important.
I haven't even looked at his
machine-learning algorithms
yet, but can we run
on Pedersen commitments, or
do we need something else?
Also, another really
important area of future work
is to optimize the
implementation.
Like I said, I think we get
at least twice as fast, if not
more.
And in conclusion,
yeah, if you want
to work on any of these
things, please let me know.
If you're interested in using
cryptographic primitives
to achieve privacy with
interesting functions,
let me know.
And this is the website for
zkLedger, which at the moment
is really just the paper.
We have a code base which is too
embarrassing to be released out
into the real world, but
we'll get there shortly,
once we clean it up.
So that's it.
So thanks for listening.
I hope you found it interesting.
[APPLAUSE]